I'll tell you a little story this is in
my book so I had this landlord in
Montreal and lived next door to me he
was an exhales angels biker he'd spend a
lot of time in prison and his wife had
borderline personality disorder and she
committed suicide when I lived there and
here's a rough guy and he was at
québécois and he spoke uol which I could
hardly understand and he didn't really
know what to make of me and I didn't
really know what to make of him but we
got along you know I was very careful
talking to him as you might imagine but
but I was it was very in lien we went
over my wife and I went over there and
we had the spaghetti dinner one night
and we sort of communicated and I bought
a poster from him because he made these
wooden posters that had neon on them and
that's how he made a living he'd kind of
trained himself to be a bit of an
electronics guy so he made these things
and he was trying to quit drinking and
we talked about that he was a lot older
than me he was like 20 years older than
me I was about 25 at this point and we
got along pretty well but every now and
then he'd go out and get and drink and
he could really drink you know like he
was one of these guys who could drink
like 60 beer and you think well no one
can drink that much and you're wrong I
studied alcohol for like ten years some
of my subjects fathers drank 40 ounces
of vodka a day and had been doing it for
20 years
so you can drink a lot and he could
drink a lot and what would happen he's
trying to not drink but he'd go out and
go on a binge and then he'd be going for
like three days and he'd drink up all
his money and then we'd hear him out in
the backyard howling at the moon with
this little little ugly dog he had you
know and he'd howling the dog would howl
and he'd howl and the dog would howl and
and it was rather unsettling and made my
wife nervous and and but worse you know
now and then he'd come to the door like
3:00 in the morning eh he'd knock on the
door and he'd be standing there and I
don't know how much experience you've
had with rough guys who are alcoholic
and who were drunk but it's they can be
upright and unconscious at the same time
and so that was the state that he was in
you know he'd be just swaying
he'd asked me if I would like to buy his
toaster or his microwave because he
needed some money to keep drinking and
you know I didn't really want to buy his
toaster or his microwave but when the
exhales angel Jew all speaking sixty
beer drunk okay but while biker shows up
at your door at 3:00 in the morning and
offers you to sell offers to sell you
his microwave huh the easiest thing is
to say I really need a microwave so so
you know I bought the microwave and the
toaster and some other things but then
but then my wife talked to me and she
like my landlord you know even though
she was afraid of him she liked him and
and she said you can't buy anymore
anymore appliances because it's not good
for him and I thought huh that's an
interesting problem you know so what the
hell am I going to do about this because
no I don't want to buy your microwave
just doesn't seem to be the right answer
at 3:00 in the morning so so one time he
took me out on his 750 Honda and he put
me on the back of it you want to show me
his lair I guess his hangouts and I got
his wife's helmet on but it didn't fit
it just sit on the top of my head and he
said I got on the bike and he said if
the cops chase us were not stopping
then away we went and we went to these
like these bars downtown on sound the
road they were very rough places he got
into like four fights that night because
he was a rough guy you know and these
kind of punk guys would come up to him
and sort of challenge him and act
stupidly around him and he was very
skeptical and if you were acting
stupidly around him pretty length of
time he just hit you because he felt
that that's what you deserved and
perhaps he was right you know so so I
had first-hand opportunity to observe
him so anyways he sure enough about a
week or two after we had this
conversation he showed up at the door
knock knock knock you know open the door
and he's standing there you know with
his eyes kind of half closed and he was
swaying
and he had I don't remember what the
appliance was this time but he wanted to
sell it to me and I said I'm not all I
can buy this I'm not going to buy this
because I know you're trying to quit
drinking and if I give you this money
then you're going to go and drink it up
and it's not going to be good for you
and what else did I tell him I think I
told him as well that this whole thing
of him coming to my house at like 2:00
in the morning
was scaring my wife who he liked and
that it had to stop and believe me man I
was thinking about what I was saying
because he was watching me like a rough
guy watches you and a rough guy watches
you like this he thinks if you say one
thing that indicates contempt you're
going to bloody well pay for it and so I
was finding my words like you know I was
crossing a swamp and trying to look for
the for the rocks underneath the surface
and I said what I had to say very very
carefully and he looked at me for about
15 seconds and that's a long time to be
looked at at 3:00 in the morning huh
and he left and he never came back to
sell me anything again and we got along
fine but that's a good illustration of
this issue with regards to truth and
success in the strange land because I
was in the strange land when I was
talking to my neighbor my landlord and
and I managed to say what was true
carefully enough so despite the fact
that he was a very violent person and
that he was a very intoxicated person
and then he had every reason to be
suspicious of me and we couldn't
communicate very well and I didn't do
what he wanted that he took it and he
left and there was no problem and life
went on just fine after that and so we
don't want to underestimate the utility
of establishing this bounded
relationship with the ideal and
attempting to live
with some nobility in truth while aiming
at the highest ideal there's nothing
about that that's anything but
strengthening and positive and it's
exactly what you need to set against the
catastrophe and uncertainty of life